[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme
clamping down on climate change
protesters an injunction bans them from
blocking the m25 while the transport
secretary threatens them with prison
two more energy companies go to the wall
amid a warning that high gas prices may
be here to stay but is that such a bad
thing for the environment
and china delivers undoubted good news
it's funding of coal-powered plants
abroad is the stop
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
now the government has got tough with
climate change protesters who've blocked
parts of the m25 five times over the
past fortnight ministers have obtained a
high court injunction banning the
demonstrations by insulate britain and
the transport secretary grant shaps has
warned that anyone who chooses to flout
the injunction risks possible
imprisonment as iva bennett reports and
you're willing to go to prison i am
willing to go to prison
first on the motorway now at the home
office climate activists are refusing to
be silenced
an injunction sought by the home
secretary has made intellect britain's
m25 protests illegal next time they
could be imprisoned but the group is
vowing to continue
the injunction changes nothing the
injunction changes nothing i've been
very clear this is more important than
my life my children's future is more
important than a bit of paper
britain's busiest motorway has been
blocked five times in the last week by
the activists who want the government to
tackle climate change through better
home insulation
traffic's come to a standstill and each
time police have made multiple arrests
we do not think it's acceptable
to go and stand on a road it's bloody
dangerous
it's obviously
inconvenient it's also completely
counterproductive
but the group says it's not trying to
please the public
it seems like you're targeting the
public though not the government with
your protests
we are disrupting the public we are
disrupting the system to say please this
system is killing us it's not working
for us the right to protest is clearly a
fundamental part of a democracy but the
injunction on this group shows that
right does come with conditions and
caveats particularly when the rights of
others to go about their daily lives are
affected
public disruption has become a hallmark
of climate activism ever since
extinction rebellion brought central
london to a standstill in 2019
it wasn't a tactic deployed by
greenpeace with their flotilla on the
thames today but they seem to agree that
right now anything goes the direct
action has got a long history in this
country of people taking peaceful direct
action and we are in an emergency so i
don't know the exact details but i do
know that protesters everywhere
including us are calling on the
government to act more quickly in the
run-up to cop
the closer we get to the climate summit
hosted in glasgow in just six weeks the
calls for action will undoubtedly get
more urgent and the way they're conveyed
may well get more extreme iva bennett
sky news
well let's get the thoughts now of our
climate change correspondent hannah
thomas peter so hannah are we seeing a
shift in the way that climate activists
are trying to get heard and will today's
move by the government affect that do
you think
well i think when you speak to
extinction rebellion activists and
certainly as that report just showed
some of these insulate britain activists
getting arrested interacting with the
justice system potentially even going to
prison
is sort of a badge of honor and i think
this specific injunction may well
discourage people in the margins of that
protest group
from continuing but it doesn't sound
like it's going to have a huge impact on
that group's philosophy and
determination to keep going i think more
broadly though the interesting point
that's been raised by insulate britain
and its ongoing attempts to block the
m25 motorway is that there has been a
real shift away from winning the hearts
and minds of people of bringing the
public along with them
towards
maximum disruption high-risk strategies
that create a lot of noise
extinction rebellion has tweeted quite
frequently in recent weeks we are not
here to be liked and i think now these
protest groups in the uk are releasing
themselves of the obligations to and the
the public and kind of the shackles of
trying to be liked and creating a
people's movement
i think it is right to assume that in
the coming weeks before the climate
summit we are going to see more and more
extreme tactics deployed
hannah thank you
now two energy suppliers avro and green
energy have announced that there to
cease trading amid a continuing surge in
gas prices the two suppliers represent a
share of nearly three percent of
domestic customers the head of the
energy regulator ofgem today warned that
more suppliers are likely to go bust
this winter and that the hike in prices
may not be temporary well that warning
was echoed by the business secretary
quasiquate
price has spiked uh considerably i've
got a chart in front of me i think it's
quadrupled
in the last uh six months seven months
and the you would expect normally that
the price would revert
uh to the mean it's not something that
we think is going to be sustainable but
of course mr jones we have to prepare
uh for longer term uh high prices
well our business correspondent helen
and smith is in westminster for us so a
warning today then that high gas prices
could be here to stay helen
but um could this prompt a new push to
boost our renewables capacity
well lots of energy analysts are saying
that this crisis shows the need if you
like to diversify our energy supply
there's been lots of focus in the last
couple of days about how uh we in the uk
get a lot of our natural gas
from imports about how we don't have a
whole lot of storage here in the uk
compared um to our continental partners
and how that leaves us quite vulnerable
um and i think lots of people accept
that we had a broader and more diverse
energy supply and some of that more of
that came from renewables that would
broadly be a good thing the reality of
whether it actually changes either sort
of industrial business or government
policy i think is a completely different
matter when it comes to businesses
just surviving this crisis at the moment
is clearly a very big problem for a lot
of energy companies we're just seeing a
lot of them
ceasing to trade and the bigger ones who
are more robust they're having to take
on hundreds of thousands of other
customers from the ones that have
collapsed and at the moment the price of
wholesale gas is so high that actually
balancing the books with all these
customers it's not necessarily certain
they'll be able to do that without
government intervention so i think kind
of plumbing putting a whole load more
money right now into accelerating uh
their drive to renewables i think a
little questionable there could be
legislative uh incentives but again the
government talk a lot about their
10-point industrial green plan that
they're proud of at the moment so again
i'm not sure whether that will come
right this second but clearly the need
to diversify is there hello nan thank
you
well gas prices have rocketed because of
supply issues so let me take you over to
our data dashboard and have a look at
the uk's real-time power mix here and
you can see that uh fossil fuels of
which gas of course makes up a huge part
of currently at 41
we've got renewables of 44
and nuclear there at 15
and the lack of wind recently has partly
contributed to the spike in gas prices
but on what's been a fairly sunny and
windy day today across much of the uk
that renewables figure was actually more
like 50 in late afternoon which is
pretty good going for renewables
and just to let you know that later on
the show we're going to be asking the
climate justice activist michaela loach
and the director of the climate think
tank e3g tom burke whether the high gas
prices could actually turn out to be a
good thing
well in some of today's other climate
news now global sea levels are rising by
3.1 millimeters per year and arctic sea
ice is declining at an alarming pace
that's according to the fifth ocean
state report by the copernicus marine
service which warns that climate change
is creating unprecedented pressure on
our oceans
the report also reveals how warmer ocean
temperatures are causing invasive
non-native species to migrate disrupting
ecosystems across the world
the southwest of the united states is in
the grip of the most severe drought on
record and scientists have confirmed
that climate change is making the
situation worse
the national oceanic and atmospheric
administration's drought task force has
found that over the 20-month period from
january 2020 to august this year the
region received the lowest amount of
rainfall since 1895.
and a volcanic eruption on the canary
island of la palma has now forced the
evacuation of more than 6 000 people
lava is slowly making its way towards
the atlantic ocean and as a result could
trigger landslides and produce clouds of
toxic gas
sky news is going to be reporting live
throughout the evening from that island
now china has promised to stop funding
new coal-powered projects in foreign
countries in a move that could
dramatically reduce the impact of fossil
fuels now the announcement was made by
the country's president xi jinping in a
pre-recorded message to the un general
assembly
we will strictly control coal-fired
power generation projects we will
strictly limit the increase in coal
consumption over the 14-5 year planned
period
and phase it down in the 15th five-year
plan period
well china currently funds over 50
billion dollars worth of coal projects
in 20 countries around the world now
along with japan and south korea china's
been responsible for more than 95
of all foreign financing for coal plants
but only this year japan and south korea
agreed to stop financing overseas coal
projects
china's announcement to follow their
lead could mean 40 gigawatts of plan
coal fired capacity in 20 developing
countries could be cancelled now that's
the equivalent of the amount of coal
that germany produces each year
but president xi's announcement doesn't
cover china's domestic coal use and the
country uses a huge amount of the fossil
fuel at home now coal accounted for 58
of china's energy usage in 2019 and last
year the country built around one large
coal plant every single week
now china plans to be carbon neutral by
2060 and that's driving growth in the
renewable sector which grew by four
percent in the first half of this year
well our china correspondent tom
cheshire has been assessing just how
important that pledge is
this was a surprising but very
significant announcement from president
xi jinping effectively according to one
analyst it ends financing for overseas
coal projects so that is a huge huge
deal now it is possible to argue that
some of that support for overseas coal
financing had been going away uh
projects linked to china had been having
difficulty getting built because of uh
environmental opposition but also
because the economics in a lot of cases
weren't adding up compared to renewable
energy but whatever the case this
certainly puts the seal on it now that
uh the highest leader of china says this
won't be happening anymore if it were to
creep back it doesn't seem like that is
going to happen so china really should
be applauded for this step i think focus
though is going to turn away from the
overseas coal financing to domestic use
of coal china still uses a huge huge
amount of coal more than any other
country and as a result it is still the
world's biggest polluter now has said it
will peak emissions by 2030 but experts
say that is rather too late especially
to avoid the worst effects of climate
change and it still continues to add to
that coal capacity so i think that's
what people are going to be asking next
especially ahead of cop the big summit
coming up will we see a dramatic pledge
a similarly dramatic pledge from xi
jinping to look not just to overseas
coal financing but to look at how china
uses coal and how it might curb it
before the targets it's already
announced
well do stay with us coming up after the
break i'm going to be joined by climate
justice activist michaela loach and tom
berg the founder and director of the
climate think tank e3g they're standing
by ready and waiting and i'm going to be
discussing with them whether china's
announcement is a turning point for cop
26 discussions and also whether higher
gas prices could be a good thing for the
climate
so we are taking people to space in a
very gentle way right i think when most
of us think about space flight
we think about rockets and training and
spacesuit the right stuff
so we want to find a way to take people
to space that's incredibly gentle so
that we all feel that we can go to space
and so we're using
a huge space balloon that is the size of
a football field taking a very
comfortable pressurized capsule to space
and of course you can have your beverage
of choice on board we have a bar and a
loo of course and wi-fi offline is six
hours long it takes you roughly two
hours to get to space you're going there
at a blazing 12 miles an hour then
you're going to be up at apogee at the
top for two hours so that you can look
out the windows 360 degree panoramic
view to have that incredible view of
earth in space that astronauts talk
about like it really moves them when
they see that view and then two hours
down again
ours costs 125 000 a piece there are of
course other ways to get to space which
are vastly more expensive so we're
pretty excited that we are going to
space but we are able to really bring
the cost down significantly already and
we're pretty excited about the the
uptake that we've had the demand is huge
we put tickets on sale earlier this year
in february we've already sold over 450
tickets so people really want to go to
space
so this is truly the safe way to go to
space the space balloon that we are
flying a pressurized capsule with
has been used by nasa and others
thousands of times and so of course it
that has really tested the technology
and put it through its paces and then
between the capsule and the balloon
there is of course a parachute and it's
a pre-deployed parachute and this kind
of system has been used also thousands
of times and has never failed in all of
that time so it's an incredibly safe way
to go to space
what's really fun is that we're seeing
people buying up four capsules so that
which is eight people and a pilot
and that way they can take their entire
family they can get a group of friends
together to go so it's really becoming a
social event in space
[Music]
we don't understand that every lake or a
pond is a habitat in itself which houses
frogs snakes crabs turtles birds so many
different life forms human beings
directly depend on underground water
source so a lake or a pond is necessary
to replenish these groundwater resources
[Music]
did you know if we tried to use less
energy we could help reduce air
pollution
what like turning off the lights and
stuff yeah
thursday brings us mixed weather
conditions with an area of cloud across
parts of wales the midlands and east
anglia that's going to push its way
southwards
one or two spots of drizzle on that and
then another rainbow starts to work its
way in from the north temperatures still
on the high side for the time of year
we're looking at a high of around 23
degrees celsius 73 degrees fahrenheit in
terms of air pollution while those
changeable conditions do benefit us in
terms of air quality
pollution will be low right across the
country
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news now we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with
climate activist michaela loach and tom
burke chairman of the e3g think tank so
welcome to you nice to see you here this
evening and uh two good bits of climate
news from the un general assembly this
week for us to discuss
joe biden as expected upping the united
states commitment to funding climate
action in the developing world and then
in more of a surprise move xi jinping
saying that china would no longer
finance coal projects abroad and with
just 40 days to go before cop 26 in
glasgow we're going to be asking is this
a turning point so tom i want to ask you
first of all about these big
announcements let's focus in on china
because i'm going to show everybody what
the un uh secretary general antonio
gutierrez has said about the issue of
coal he said accelerating the global
phase out of coal is the single most
important step in keeping the paris
agreement's key warning limit within
reach so this announcement by china is
it a key breakthrough ahead of cop26
i don't know that it's it's quite a
breakthrough but it's certainly a very
important development and it
it more so because it was a bit
unexpected and i think that's helped to
change the tone of the conversation as
we run in it was getting to be a bit
gloomy and and now i think together with
the biden announcement this announcement
particularly because of as the secretary
general was saying how important coal is
i think this has lifted the tone and
begun to put a little bit of momentum
into it but i think it's a bit early to
say it's an actual breakthrough okay so
to make it a breakthrough would china
have to say we're going to make the same
announcement as far as our domestic coal
production is concerned because they
rely so much on it in the country don't
they
i think that's exactly right as tom uh
showed us just a minute ago i think that
would that really would be a
breakthrough if they were to make the
commitment to phase out coal with a
deadline uh a little bit before 2060
then i think we'd really be looking at
something you could count as a
breakthrough
okay michaela that's china let's talk
about president biden's announcement as
well on climate finance uh doubling
finance to uh developing countries uh to
11 billion dollars i mean climate
finance has been a big sticking point so
does this give you
some sense of positivity that climate
justice can be achieved at cop
that's a really good question um
i think when it comes to the united
states i am quite hesitant about um
celebrating a kind of a move from
climate denial to climate delay because
what we actually need is climate action
and both climates now and climate change
give us an unlivable future and what we
actually need is a livable future and
that means
moving beyond this kind of bare minimum
they still haven't met the 100 billion
um target they need for this climate and
fund and actually that's not even enough
i think if you consider how much the
part to play the united states and
countries like the uk have had in the
creation of this crisis and continuing
to perpetuate so many emissions i think
what we actually need to hear in cop26
is how um all of these nations listening
to the countries that are most affected
and the people who are most effective
and indigenous needles and all these
people and listening to what climate
justice means for those people rather
than um almost passing themselves on the
back for doing what i see is almost less
than the bare minimum
and where does this leave us do you
think then tom i mean cop 21 the paris
agreement was reached it was
deemed a huge success could the same
happen for cop 26 in november
i think you need a different uh a kind
of different measure of success what
paris was about was really trying to put
together a global agreement to deal with
the problem i think what we're now
looking at are the steps we have to take
to implement that agreement and this is
a really important one of those steps
and i think michaela's right to be a
little bit cautious about what the
americans are saying about money it's
not the president of the united states
that decides how much money america can
give but u.s congress and that's a
little bit less uh focused on climate
justice than the president is okay so so
i think that we mustn't raise our
expectations too high uh for the cop i
think it's
some real progress being made in the
last few days i think we've got to see
some more uh in the interim period
between now and the cop itself so we
need to be looking at the g20 meeting uh
next month very briefly michaela can cop
26 be a success does this bode well
i think that's yeah that's a that's also
a difficult question because i think
considering how many nations aren't even
able to make it to the cop how many
indigenous leaders how many of the most
affected people and countries aren't
being able to make it there i find it
difficult to know whether this will be
the success that um
maybe we need it to be um it seems
especially from what boris johnson is
saying almost applauding himself and
then using water baptism and talking
about china and india rather than the
uk's huge emissions and their investment
in fossil fuels and that it's going to
be almost like all of these countries
coming together to talk about how great
they are rather than actually addressing
the real harm that's being caused okay
lovely i'm going to rush us on to the
next subject we're running out of time
and sky news has been reporting on an
energy supply crisis all week energy
firms going out of business rocketing
prices but in the context of climate
change are high gas prices a good thing
and kyla i'm just going to take a look
at what quasi quattang has said our
exposure to volatile global gas prices
underscores the importance uh there of a
strong homegrown renewable energy sector
so what's bad for consumers now michaela
could this could be a good in terms of
renewable energy and the planet
i'm i'm hesitant to say this is this is
a good thing that is happening right now
but what i will say is it's bringing
attention to the fact that um gas is
unsustainable um financially but also
obviously for the planet and what we
actually need to be doing is moving
towards a renewable economy that
actually will be there for the future is
sustainable for the future but also
won't have these same fluctuations in
prices and will be better for all of us
but do we not need a gas tom to switch
it on when wind lets us down or the sun
lets us down
we can
develop a an energy system that doesn't
need gas at all and in fact if what
we've done was what we could have done
in insulating the leakiest homes in
europe and deploying the renewables that
we've got faster than what we've done
not only would we have driven people's
bills down rather than putting them up
but we would reduce our vulnerability to
these kind of price spikes caused by
international resource markets so in a
sense the real signal from this
is to get on with what we know we can do
to reduce our vulnerability both to the
climate and to high energy prices it's a
huge job though isn't it michael is so
many of our houses are powered by gas
aren't they
yeah but i also think that there's a
huge like opportunity that we have here
to realize the necessity and kind of
immediacy of our need to invest in these
um renewables instead and create a green
economy where we don't have this
reliance on such um fragile industries
as the gas industry we know that this is
a declining industry we've known that
for such a long time and we need to be
moving away from that i think that we
can see this as an opportunity to really
take that on board and actually
mean that all of us can actually access
um energy that is not unstable is
sustainable and is safe and better for
all of us we must leave it there but i
can see you're dying to say something
tom very in 10 seconds
yeah
anna's right opportunity is a better
driver of change than punishment okay
beautifully succinct tom burke mckaylan
notes we must leave it there thanks both
very much indeed thank you so we're out
of time do stay tuned sky news tonight
coming up with dermot and i'll be back
again tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
you